this commencement is here to remind us
why we're here what do we commit the
subject of commencement is the good luck
the first graduating class is from
Hillsdale College graduated into a world
of the most disastrous war that our
country has ever known and the question
is what can see them through both these
good times and the bad times that are
both bound to come to everyone in this
audience today and the answer is virtue
and faith and freedom and knowledge
wherever I go the world will be a fallen
one not because of this or that
political system though some are much
better than others it will be a fallen
world because I am in it human nature
has not changed ideas are actually
rather rare these days we're full of
ideology but not ideas do not give to a
mere idea the love that year olds
reality and the reverence of your life
in our time at Hillsdale College you
sought truth as we graduate and bring
the fruits of our perseverance we live
in a world that has lost sight of truth
in a very fundamental way we have in
fact come to shoot through an experience
through the experience of this community
of truth seekers the liberal arts
education that is capable of
understanding something about how the
world works the more you learn the more
you ought to understand that you have so
much more to our learning will and can
never come to an end
[Music]